[Music]  RTC celebrating 30 years of Transit here  in southern Nevada and the transit  system recognized several drivers today  along with mechanics and other service  staff who have kept the community moving  over these last three decades they  receive custom bus stop plaques to honor  their continuous service for many they  say they are proud to have grown with  RTC especially as the valley continues  to expand  I've been here in 92 as always only  three hundred thousand so I've seen a  lot of changes I did Rainbow for years  and back then from trump it would only  take you 30 minutes to go from Trap to  low mountain now it takes like an hour  and a half  RTC says as it celebrated its robust  past it's also looking to the future  with new Investments and routes to  elevate the lives of Southern Nevada  residents and visitors